so how our council decide what to do in
our district we want to hear what you
think the question is simple do you
support shops opening for trading on
Easter Sunday for me personally I shot I
don't think that today on Sundays with
the Bible or at least better day I think
the good opportunity committee that's
our plan teves last weekend for their
family and wouldn't like pletely trading
that as national yes I depend a lot and
retail sales during weekends and public
holidays are probably at our house
myself it's really important for you yes
it's the difference between make and
break so you've heard what they have to
say what do you think let's talk we can
make your feedback nine on our website
Facebook or at any of our service center
Easter trading is just one topic covered
in a draft and your plan visit
Waimakariri govt thieves or indeed to
find out more and have your say
[Applause]
[Music]